so the Matrix is now coming after
Russell Brand the comedian actor
podcaster who has been loved by many for
years and now after his whole career you
know everyone loves him now after 20
years now he's a a rapist sexual assaul
even though there's no police report
let's check it out are some very serious
allegations that I absolutely refute
these allegations pertain to the time
when I was working in the mainstream
when I was in the newspapers the time
when I was in the movies and as I've
written about extensively in my books I
was very very promiscuous now during
that time of promiscuity the
relationships I had were absolutely
always consensual I was always
transparent about that then almost too
transparent and I'm being transparent
about it now as well and to see that
transparency metastasized into something
criminal that I absolutely deny makes me
question is there another agenda at play
particularly when we've seen coordinated
media attacks before like with Joe Rogan
when he dared to take a medicine that
the mainstream media didn't approve of
and we saw a Spate of headlines from
media Outlets across the world using the
same language I'm aware that you guys
have been saying in the comments for a
while watch out Russell they're coming
for you you're getting too close to the
truth Russell Brand did not kill himself
I know that a year ago there was a Spate
of Articles Russell br's a conspiracy
theorist Russell br's right wing I'm
aware of news media making phone calls
sending letters to people I know for
ages and ages it's been clear to me or
at least it feels to me like there's a
serious and concerted agenda to control
these kind of spaces and these kind of
voices and I mean my voice along with
your voice I don't mind them using my
books and my stand up to talk about my
promiscuous consensual conduct in the
past what I seriously refute are these
very very serious criminal allegations
also it's worth mentioning that there
are witnesses whose evidence directly
contradicts The Narrative that these two
mainstream media Outlets are trying to
construct apparently in what seems to me
to be a coordinated attack now I don't
want to get into this any further
because of the serious nature of the
allegations but I feel like I'm being
attacked and plainly they are working
very closely together we are obviously
going to look into this matter cuz it's
very very serious in the meantime I want
you to stay close stay awake but more
important than any of that if you can
please stay free okay so I have a couple
questions where is the police
report why would you wait five 10 years
to come out and why would a man that is
Rich and Famous need to rape anybody I
mean gu like guys let's just put two and
two together the men like Drake have
women throwing hundreds of bras on
stage why would a
guy need to to assault or rape
anybody in order to get sex that's
having it thrown at him 247 this is the
equivalent okay this is the
equivalent of me being a billionaire and
getting accused of robbing a bank I
I I I don't believe this this is the
same thing they did the Tate this is the
same thing they've done to Noel Clark
this is the same thing that they've done
to comedian
politician basically any guy that
decides to tell the truth and go against
the mainstream narrative
they they throw all these allegations at
and I think we need to get to a point
where I I mean guys we have to be a bit
skeptical that rich famous men are are
raping women like that I mean this
really doesn't make any sense and my
question is what is assault what we need
we need to get clear definitions so we
can determine if this stuff happened but
now now we say consent what is consent
what's not consent and it just gets
really confusing to the general public
so you know we can wait till the facts
come out of the case but I just I have a
hard time believing that any guy that is
Rich and Famous really needs to rape
women like that
sorry for being the one to say it but
that's just my opinion on it
so and and what I see guys and this is
just general Trends is women really like
typically what happens is they come out
years later they come out and and my
question is to those women why would you
wait years okay I'll give you a week
I'll give you two weeks I'll even maybe
give you a month
but uh 10 years later now he's an abuser
10 years later now he's a rapist um and
and until I see police reports and
substantial evidence proving these
claims I I just and I think it's
actually wrong and I think the news
outlets should be held accountable for
reporting on stories with zero evidence
I think they should be held accountable
for labeling a guy a criminal without
telling two sides of the story and guys
you know this is what happened to Steven
Crowder in front of our eyes you know
I'm going to be doing a stream on him
either tonight or tomorrow very similar
it's on the right and the left